yeah is that so the Marches it's got to
stay fresh and after you opening you
want to keep in the freezer and yep you
got a freezer and you'd sift it so it
doesn't form lumps and then you whisk it
with that traditional bamboo whisk or
you buy a little electric whisker and
you can whisk it in hot water or cold
water and it's very yummy and what what
what does it do for you like what's the
good well you've got it's got caffeine
of course so you get stimulated by it
but it's also got l-theanine which is
this relaxant compound that modifies the
effect of caffeine and produces a state
of relaxed alertness so it doesn't have
the jangling effect of coffee right and
you're getting all of these antioxidant
benefits that are well-documented tea
anyway I love it it's a great thing
anytime you get one of these little
whisks it's cool it's like a real bamboo
made from one piece of bamboo
it's a miracle of Japanese craftsmanship
it's beautiful and it's beautiful so how
often you drink this stuff I have a bowl
of it every morning in civilian yeah I'm
sometimes I have a glass of iced matcha
later in the day especially in warm
weather you just a matcha fiend I love
it it's a good thing I first tasted it
when I was 17 I was an exchange student
in Japan in 1959 I lived with a family
outside of Tokyo we had no language in
common and on the second night I was
there the mother took me next door to
her neighbors who practice tea ceremony
and they did this thing for me and I was
fascinated by that whisk and the color
of the matcha and I thought it was great
you know I never thought I'd be able to
get it over here
yeah well so you you import this stuff
yourself
I started a company called matcha quarry
we've got the URL matcha calm and I went
to Japan to you G which is a little town
outside of Kyoto where which is the
center of the best tea production in
Japan and I sourced really good matcha
you know there are many grades in matcha
the most the highest are too expensive
to use for everyday used it really yeah
I mean phenomics like truffles or yeah
yeah really expensive so you I've tried
to find the best matcha that is
affordable and make it available to
people here so like the highest level
stuff how much would it cost for a cup
of tea hard to estimate for a cup you
know possibly there's a preparation
called thick tea in Japan where they use
three times the amount of
alder and probably one bowl of that
stuff we just shared by several people I
don't know it could be a hundred dollars
of old
whoa yeah really yeah t yeah well why
did it catch on in Japan like that it's
always been you know it has been in
Japan for a very long time and and this
powdered tea preparation was originally
taken up by Zen monks to help them stay
awake during long hours and meditation
was also associated with samurai and
became the tea ceremony developed around
that is there anything that is similar
to it is like your vomit a or guarana or
any other well these are all channeling
they're all caffeine plants but in my
experience tea I think in this primarily
because of that l-theanine content mmm
the effect is mellower of caffeine so
you get stimulated you get alert but it
doesn't have the jangling affective a
lot of these other caffeine beverages
mm-hmm do you drink regular coffee as
well no I've never drunk coffee Wow I
think I was turned off because my
parents when I was going up drank really
strong black coffee with no sugar cream
I couldn't imagine what people would
savages yeah those people there were
different people did you grow up in a
northern climate I grew up in
Philadelphia yeah see it's when it's
cold outside on people they drink that
black coffee uh-huh makes you angry the
world yeah
dark black burnt coffee I like bright
green shining Masha